police in India are being accused of
using unauthorized and excessive force
against protesters at New Delhi is jammy
at university around two weeks ago and
an independent investigations found that
officers indiscriminately beat
demonstrators destroyed public property
and arrested people unlawfully these are
also being accused of intimidation and
firing on protesters it would hurt
Pradesh where 18 people were killed the
demonstrations are against a new
citizenship law that's been labeled as
anti-muslim let's cross over to
Elizabeth puranam whose joins us now
from the Indian capital with the very
latest on that investigation Elizabeth
[Music]
hi so we are here at Jamia Millia
Islamia University which was the which
has been the center of protest for the
last two weeks and it's actually protest
that took place here or rather the
police response to protests which took
place here on December 13th and December
15th
soon after the citizenship law was
passed that led to protests phenom at
universities around the country not just
against the law but the police responds
to the protest and we're joined now by
an indica que thon she was part of the
team the fact-finding team that looked
into the police response and at the
university's protest and you think and
thank you very much for being with us at
Ella's and I know your investigation
says that the your report found a
picture what you call of police terror
at jamia who did you speak to and what
did you find
we spoke to several students on campus
who are eyewitnesses to various accounts
that had started happening from the 13th
of December onwards we were visited
hospitals we spoke to staff at hospitals
injured students and their family is
there and we also spoke to several local
residents in the area and when it comes
to our findings I think three or four
things to emphasize first the
unauthorized entry of police in the
campus didn't just happen on Sunday the
15th but in fact also on the 13th of
December because on the 13th of December
the police had again disallow the
students from conducting a protest march
again use indiscriminate latitia
in yoga shelling all the way back to
campus and even on Friday had entered
campus without permission cause damage
to lots of vehicles parked inside that
are completely unrelated to the protest
and Lahti charged students there when it
comes to the events of Sunday itself the
police version is that they needed to
use a certain amount of violence to
quell a violent more however when you
look at the nature of injuries that were
inflicted on the students we found
multiple students who suffered grave
injuries to their head and looking at
the nature of injuries it seemed that
the violence used by the police was not
simply by
can be justified when it comes to a
light control measure second when it
comes to the entry of police on to
campus when we visit a jamia the
following day we found blood on the
steps of the mosque we found broken
locks and entries CCTV cameras that have
been broken accounts now the police was
trying to create an atmosphere of terror
and panic on the campus and third we
found that this atmosphere of terror
carried on even after campus when it
came to hospitals and jails because
students were detained and denied
medical help for hours and I know that
you're calling for police to investigate
for a commission of inquiry but how
likely do you think that is given the
sorts of things we're hearing from the
government which is completely defending
police actions the High Court and the
Supreme Court Board had the chance to
intervene and could have taken up these
actions sumoto as well given the news
media reports it came out unfortunately
neither Court has done so the chance of
it therefore happening is anyone's guess
but yeah pure er eh rates which demand
that a commission of inquiry has to be
set up and FII registered against the
police for its action as well as the
police force in these stations need to
be sensitized because while the violence
that happened to students on campus
happened amidst a barrage of communal
abuses and it was also located in a
longer history of police like action in
this area and therefore these police
officers who need to face this reaction
will be shifted out of these stations
and also need to be sensitized to make
sure this doesn't happen again thank you
very much so that was an ethical Katelyn
part of the fact-finding team and we've
also had these teams investigate not
what happened not just what happened at
universities but as you mentioned so
violence in the state of Uttar Pradesh
watch so again the police is very much
and the government under pressure now
over what's been happening in these
protests it even or continue to follow
events with you through the day
Elizabeth Rhonda now our reporter in
Newtown